let's go next to jc from brussels jc
welcome to the program
hi can you hear me yes i can
okay um
did you hear that last year
this data company called morning consult
did a survey uh in a number of western
countries
to see how much of the population had
what they call the authoritarian
personality
have you heard you have you heard of
this yes i have i don't remember what
the results were but i remember the
survey
yes uh it turns out that about 26
of americans have highly authoritarian
personalities sounds about right whereas
only 6.7
of germans do um that's interesting
that's quite an a historical irony i
mean germany used to be the land of the
nazis but now they are the most liberal
country in the western hemisphere is
that true judged judged howe
yes i
if if you go to the wikipedia article
for the
authoritarian personality uh all the
data is there and in most of the
european countries uh only 10 or so of
the population is highly authoritarian
ah because there's other ways to
evaluate it like i i found another study
here which has germany ninth in most
left wing and it says the most left-wing
countries are norway sweden denmark
finland iceland new zealand switzerland
canada
then germany now i think the difference
is
you're talking about a survey i think of
the people
whereas this might be a survey more of
of what is government policy
well
okay yeah there was just eight countries
in that survey ah
nor scandinavia was not part of it
oh they didn't even include it well that
doesn't if you're talking about the west
i think you must include scandinavia
don't you think
yeah but um i they only did eight
countries okay but i think
it's still
but you're right canada is pretty
liberal yeah i mean when there's almost
200 countries to only look at eight and
say germany's the most liberal seems a
little narrow
yeah it's true but still it's pretty
scary how authoritarian america is oh
it's horrific
americans like to think of themselves as
the great freedom-loving people but yeah
the data they're not they're the most
authoritarian people in the developed
world yeah well the american right is
all about the freedom to live
however you want as long as it's okay
with them
yeah conformism right
well jc thank you for the call how's
brussels these days one of my favorite
cities in the world
oh yeah the weather's nice
right we got we got spared the worst of
the heat wave nice good well i hope to
get back there sooner than later
okay see ya all right
uh jc not that excited for my triumphant
return to belgium but that's okay that's
okay